.
>>> ONLY 32 DAYS UNTIL THE ALL
IMPORTANT MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
REPUBLICANS ARE RALLYING BEHIND
THE AGENDA THAT THEY WILL ENACT
IF THEY CAN FLIP ONE OR BOTH
CHAMBERS OF CONGRESS.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAVE RELEASED
THEIR COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
KEVIN McCARTHY HAS PROMISED
THAT THE HOUSE RESOLUTION NUMBER
ONE WILL BE A REPEAL OF THE
FUNDING FOR 87000 NEW IRS AGENTS
TO HARASS YOU.
OTHER REPUBLICANS ARE ALSO
PROMISING IMMEDIATE OVERSIGHT OF
THE IRS INCLUDING INVESTIGATION
DELAYS IN ISSUING TAX REFUNDS,
FOR EXAMPLE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND TED CRUZ ARE
PUTTING HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY MAYORKAS ON NOTICE
THAT HE COULD FACE IMPEACHMENT
AT THE SITUATION AT THE BORDER
IF IT DOESN'T IMPROVE SOON AND
SIGNIFICANTLY.
WHILE SENATOR TED CRUZ IS
PREDICTING A RED TSUNAMI IN
NOVEMBER, THAT'S ONLY GOING TO
HAPPEN IF ALL OF YOU, EVERYBODY
TURNS OUT TO VOTE IN 32 DAYS.
THAT'S WHY HE IS NOW ON A 17
STATE BUS TOUR.
BARNSTORMING THE COUNTRY FOR
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ JOINS US
NOW IN UTAH TONIGHT.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU, SENATOR.
I NOTICED ONE THING GOING ON IN
UTAH AND I WANT TO POINT IT OUT.
A FORTUNE IS COMING FROM OUTSIDE
OF THE STATE IN THE SMEAR
ATTACKS, A LOT OF SLANDER
AGAINST SENATOR MIKE LEE WHO HAS
DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB.
A TRUE CONSTITUTIONALIST LIKE
YOURSELF.
WE CALL HIM EGG MCMUFFIN, EVAN
MCMULLEN, IS OUT THERE
PRETENDING TO BE SOMETHING THAT
HE'S NOT.
HE IS A ROMNEY REPUBLICAN.
I HOPE THE PEOPLE IN UTAH ARE
SMART ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND.
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS RACE IN UTAH, MIKE LEE,
UNFORTUNATELY HAS A REAL RACE.
I AM CAMPAIGNING FOR MIKE.
MIKE IS PHENOMENAL.
MIKE LEE IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
SENATORS EVER TO HAVE SERVED IN
THE UNITED STATES AND IS.
HE'S A BRILLIANT CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR.
HE'S A FIERCE AND FEROCIOUS
FIGHTER OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR
A DECADE.
MIKE AND I HAVE BEEN
SIDE-BY-SIDE AND SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER FIGHTING TO DEFEND
FREEDOM AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION AND TO MERGE OUR
OWN PARTY TO STAND UP AND
ACTUALLY DO WHAT WE PROMISE TO
DO.
HERE IN UTAH THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING SOMETHING REALLY DECEPTIVE
AND DISHONEST.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT RUN A
QUOTE, DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE.
THEY DECIDED NOT TO NOMINATE
ANYONE AT ALL.
INSTEAD YOU HAVE MCMUFFIN WHO IS
THEORETICALLY RUNNING AS AN
INDEPENDENT.
HE'S RUNNING AS AN INDEPENDENT
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
ENDORSED HIM.
THEY ARE RAISING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THROUGH ACTIVE BLUE, THE
SAME ENTITY THEY USED TO SUPPORT
BERNIE SANDERS AND ELIZABETH
WARREN AND AOC.
HE VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN.
HE SUPPORTS JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES.
AMAZINGLY ENOUGH MCMUFFIN ALSO
SAID HE WOULD SUPPORT S1 WHICH
IS SCHUMER'S NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY, THE CORRUPT
POLITICIANS ACT THAT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY STRIKE DOWN EVERY
VOTER INTEGRITY LAW ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IT WOULD STRIKE DOWN PHOTO ID
REQUIREMENTS.
IT WOULD STRIKE DOWN
PROHIBITIONS ON BALLOT
HARVESTING.
IT WOULD AUTOMATICALLY REGISTER
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS TO
VOTE.
IT WOULD STRIKE DOWN
PROHIBITIONS ON FELONS VOTING
BECAUSE APPARENTLY THE DEMOCRATS
THINK WE NEED MORE MURDERERS AND
RAPISTS CHOOSING OUR LEADERS.
THIS RACE, WHAT MAKES IT
DANGEROUS, IS THEY ARE COUNTING
ON DECEPTION.
THEIR OBJECTIVE IS TO WIN ALL
THE DEMOCRATS AND JUST A
HANDFUL, MAYBE 5% OR 10% OF THE
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE NOT PAYING
MUCH ATTENTION AND SAY GOSH,
ISN'T HE A NICE GUY?
HE IS NOT A NICE GUY WHEN HE IS
COMPLICIT IN THE CULTURAL
MARXISTS THAT ARE DOING DAMAGE
TO THIS COUNTRY.
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOUR VIEWERS
TO GO SUPPORT MIKE LEE.
GO TO HIS WEBSITE AND MAKE A
CONTRIBUTION.
SUPPORT HIM.
I AM HERE CAMPAIGNING FOR HIM
BECAUSE HE NEEDS TO WIN AND THE
PEOPLE NEED TO HEAR THE TRUTH.
MIKE WILL WIN DECISIVELY.
THIS IS A CLOSE AND REAL RACE.
>> WE ARE ALSO IN PLAY IN
NEVADA.
BLAKE MASTERS HAD A GREAT
DEBATE.
GENERAL BALDOCK NOW WITHIN THE
MARGIN OF ERROR IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
WE HAVE A PLAY THERE.
TIFFANY SMILEY.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT MURPHY
WOULD HAVE BEEN VULNERABLE.
SHE IS.
THEN RON JOHNSON, JD VANCE,
DOCTOR OZ, HERSCHEL WALKER.
I'M NOT THAT WORRIED ABOUT
SENATOR KENNEDY OR RAND PAUL OR
TIM SCOTT IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
BUT I DON'T TAKE ANYTHING FOR
GRANTED.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS COMING
DOWN AT THE END OF THE DAY?
WHAT REPUBLICANS WILL GET
CONTROL OF THE SENATE?
>> I DO.
I THINK WE WILL WIN BOTH HOUSES.
I PUT THE CHANCES OF OUR WINNING
THE HOUSE AT NORTH OF 90%.
I THINK THERE IS A REAL CHANCE
WE DON'T JUST WIN THE HOUSE BUT
WE WIN WITH A BIG MAJORITY,
SOMETHING LIKE 30, 40 OR 50
SEATS IN THE SENATE.
I PUT OUR ODDS OF WINNING THE
SENATE AT ABOUT 65-35.
WE ARE 2-1 FAVORITE TO WIN.
I WOULD PREDICT WE COME OUT AT
53 REPUBLICANS.
YOU MENTIONED THAT I AM IN THE
MIDDLE OF A MONTH-LONG 17 STATE
BUS TOUR.
WE STARTED SEVEN DAYS AGO.
WE STARTED IN TOMBALL, TEXAS
JUST NORTH OF HOUSTON.
WE WENT DOWN TO THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY.
WE DID RALLIES AND THEN WE WENT
TO NEW MEXICO AND DID A BIG
RALLY.
THEN WE WENT TO ARIZONA AND DID
TWO RALLIES IN TUCSON AND
PHOENIX.
THEN WE WENT TO NEVADA AND DID A
BIG RALLY IN LAS VEGAS.
NOW WE ARE IN UTAH.
FROM UTAH WE GO ON TO MISSOURI
AND KANSAS AND IOWA AND OHIO AND
PENNSYLVANIA AND VIRGINIA AND
NORTH CAROLINA AND TENNESSEE AND
GEORGIA AND FLORIDA AND THEN
BACK UP TO MICHIGAN.
BACK UP TO WISCONSIN AND WE
CLOSE IT OUT BACK IN THE GREAT
STATE OF TEXAS.
ALL IN ALL WE ARE SUPPORTING 35
CANDIDATES IN 25 STOPS IN 17
STATES.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU WE ARE
SEEING ENERGY.
WE ARE SEEING PASSION.
PEOPLE ARE READY TO THROW THESE
LUNATICS OUT WHO HAVE DONE SO
MUCH DAMAGE TO THE COUNTRY.
I THINK WE A